thanks for joining us America this is
the Dave Ramsey show open phones a
triple a eight two five five two two
five natalie is in Abilene Texas hi
Natalie how are you very good Dave thank
you good how can I help
well my husband and I got married in
April we cashflow to our wedding plans
we had plans to get a debt free you know
aggressively you know working two jobs
and overtime and stuff and of course God
had different plans and we're now
expecting we got pregnant a month after
mm-hmm
it's been a it hasn't been an easy
pregnancy as needed physical therapy and
things like that and and so now we're
just trying to my company I've had
several budget cuts this year due to
Medicaid cost because we work with
Medicaid clients and so now we're just
getting really nervous because the baby
is due next year our insurance rates
thanks to healthcare.gov are doubling it
will be 950 to 1050 for a Fant our
family which is twice what we're paying
now and I'm taking us of your budget cut
for the three months I'll be home and
hopefully I can come back to work
full-time and we're just trying to
figure out how much does a baby cost how
do we budget for this do we put our
student loans on hold so we stopped
paying 401 K
I mean we're six years out paying 2,300
a month aggressively for student loans
and that's not counting the thousand
dollars a month that we've been told we
should set aside for the baby for
daycare and diapers and all these things
so we're just we're trying to budget
we're trying to be proactive and not get
surprised but we don't I mean we don't
even know what numbers to use gotcha
okay well the first thing is is we tell
folks not to be investing in their 401 K
while they're getting out of debt so
stop that okay so I thought that was
only for like the two years or no you're
gonna be out of that you're going to be
out of how much student loan debt do you
have a hundred and sixty-five good lord
who's the doctor or lawyer I have a
master's degree from a private
university it was before I knew of you
and my parents had no idea
so what is your household income we
bring home net on on average about 4,800
and we're putting a thousand dollars of
fat every month right now just second so
you're you're at 60,000 so you're making
about 75 80 thousand dollars a year and
you got a hundred and sixty-five
thousand dollars what is your master's
in occupational therapy why are you not
making more I know I don't know budget I
mean Medicaid every time Medicaid I'm
not talking about the stupid company you
work for your career is worth more than
you're being paid the average
occupational therapist in Texas makes
seventy five to eighty thousand a year I
I can't I mean I would love to know for
which company I left New York City for
Abilene for a pay raise and I still I
mean I my maximum has been like 65 to 70
on a high year yeah but that's not
what's what your whole family's making
what does your husband make he makes a
close thirty thousand a year what does
he do he is a industrial rehab
technician for a company here in town
they do drug screenings and physical
fitness readings she has a bachelor's
and um exercise science yeah so I mean
all right so let's stop stop a second
the thing is you guys are going to be
maximizing your income you're going to
stop doing any 401k and you're going to
stop paying any extra on your student
loans right now when you have a baby on
the way that's what we always suggest
and you pile up cash as high as you can
pile it and when baby comes and the
adjustments are made to the house and
may everybody's okay and you're okay and
everything's fine we settle into the
rhythm of our life again then we push
play again on our Total Money Makeover
at that point you don't start your 401k
but you're going to have to attack the
student loan debt and both of you are
going to have to really do a lot to
maximize your careers long term and do
anything you can short term to increase
income neither one of you are doing very
well with your degrees no or not and
that's what's frustrating us I don't
know how
maybe my doing what I went to school to
do it's a great career well you know all
I'm saying is you've got some work to do
in that area I don't know that we solve
it in this thing here now I don't know
that a baby costs $1,000 a month unless
daycare does make there's $600 a month
we've already got a spot for her and
that's the average here in this city
okay all right well then you probably
are going to spend that because you're
going to have doctor's visits and
certainly going to have formula and
diapers and other stuff so that's fine
and what are you paying for housing $700
on our mortgage okay then you can do
this you can do this you make the
student loans or it may take a while but
as your income goes up you just don't
increase lifestyle and you start
applying that to the student loans and
begin again clean the student loans up
long term but it's going to be a while
for you start investing again you've got
a mess on your hands and so but you
don't need to panic the panic in your
voice needs to leave you're okay you
make plenty of money to eat and feed a
baby the baby is going to be fine and
pay your rent and that kind of stuff the
only question is how are you going to
move your future along and your future
involves getting rid of student loan
debt and your future involves you know
getting back into the 401k and that kind
of stuff and you're not going to move
that along as fast as you want to until
you're able to both of you get more out
of more income created out of your out
of your degree fields and you should be
but is that does that have to be fixed
today no it doesn't have to be fixed as
as we fix for you to bring a baby into
the world now calm down you're okay you
make enough to pay your rent eat and
take care of the baby and do you make
enough to do that and pay off $10,000 a
month towards student loans no you don't
but you're going to be okay so just just
begin to prioritize it out and I would
stop paying extra on anything and just
pile up cash baby comes if you've got an
extra pile of cash then we restart we
start attacking the student loans again
we start the careers we relook and what
can we do there what extra can we work
what can we do here what can we cut
there and then you just keep attacking
you get back in attack mode on the
student loan at that point but the
problem
the thing that's giving you stress is
you got like six things on your plate in
front of you
two of which you don't need to worry
about today and the others you can do so
that as soon as you do that then all of
a sudden your pulse rates going to go
down and you're going to be fine you're
in better shape than you feel like you
are because you're panicking really
about things that are future-oriented
and that can be addressed with shifts in
your all's career over time but Wow hey
thanks for the call we appreciate you
joining us hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
Oh